[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes au palais du roi
de rome à rambouillet voici le sommaire
classé monument historique en 1995 le
palais du roi de rome à rambouillet
abrite le musée d'art et d'histoire une
nouvelle exposition temporaire sur
l'évolution de l'architecturé bord de
mer en france est visible jusqu'au 8 mai
un nouveau concours numérique est
organisée par les archives
départementales des yvelines jusqu'au 23
avril les participants devront résoudre
une enquête à partir de documents
d'archivés et enfin l'artiste de
renommée mondiale ian brown expose ses
oeuvres à la graineterie ah oui il a
aussi spécialement réalisé des
installations pour le centre d'art
je me trouve devant le palais du roi de
rome à rambouillet c'est ici que s'est
installé le musée d'art et d'histoire il
est ouvert toute l'année en période
d'exposition temporaire el gahs roulier
bonjour un jour vous êtes la directrice
du musée alors il est installé dans la
partie au public du monument avant de
parler de ses missions un peu d'histoire
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter le
passé de ces lieux oui bien sûr donc le
palais du roi and roll c'est un bâtiment
d'époque empire qui en fait a pris la
place d'un bâtiment précédent construit
sous le règne de louis saez qui
s'appelait hôtel du gouvernement était
destiné à abriter le gouverneur de
rambouillet lorsqu'il venait en séjour
ici pour surveiller les travaux
commandés par le roi notamment est donc
sous la révolution ce bâtiment a été
vendu très abîmé et quand il est
retourné dans le giron de l'état au
début de l'an pire en fait on a décidé
de le reconstruire en réalité on a
conservé les ailes des communs mais on a
reconstruit le corps noble donc on l'a
appelée second total du gouvernement est
la dénomination palais du roi de rome
s'est imposée uniquement au xxème siècle
en mémoire du fait que l'empereur
l'avait offert à son fils voilà le roi
d'europe développe donc le palais du roi
drame ce bâtiment est classé aux
monuments historiques incessants en 1995
pourquoi il a été classé alors il a été
classé il a d'abord été inscrits classé
monument historique pour la partie
publique la partie privée il ya
simplement faire l'objet d'un classement
très récemment donc maintenant c'est
l'ensemble du monument qui et qui est
protégé au titre des monuments
historiques il a été classé parce que
c'était un monument qui a la foi était
liée à l'histoire impériale donc c'est
le seul le seul palais le seul hôtel
particulier qui était affecté à un usage
privé de l'enfant du de l'aiglon du roi
de rome puisque le projet prévu sur la
colline de chaillot n'a jamais vu le
jour d'une part et d'autre part parce
que c'était un témoin tout à fait rare
de l'influencé architecture toscane de
la renaissance sur l'architecturé
française au début du 19e siècle donc on
est vraiment sur un moment d'histoire de
l'art voilà qui va pas durer très
longtemps donc c'est cet aspect là qui a
voulu être conservé on l'a dit m artix
public et une partie privée nous on va
s'attarder bien sûr sur la partie
publique on l'a dit en course a créé au
musée d'art et d'histoire de nous
diriger qu'est ce que l'on peut
découvrir
alors c'est un musée municipal tout
d'abord donc qui présente au
rez-de-chaussée les collections
municipales et à l'étagé des expositions
temporaires donc par le passé le palais
du roi de rome a plutôt été une galerie
d'exposants portr et puis depuis
quelques années on fait évoluer ses
missions pour valoriser les collections
municipales donc actuellement il est
encore ouvert uniquement en période
d'expo temporaire ce qui est l'héritage
du passé mais nous allons faire de
grands changements puisque durant l'été
nous allons fermer pour faire des
travaux pour faire un grand ménage pour
revoir la scénographie du rez de
chaussée voilà avoir un accrochage
permanent pérenne des collections
rouvrir les bêtes pour redonner de la
lumière que les bébés tout été occulté
et puis quelques petites choses que le
public découvrira donc on y parlera pas
en avance et ensuite nous ouvrirons en
permanence voilà comme un vrai musée
d'accord ce sera quand à partir des
journées du patrimoine troisième
week-end de septembre ok très bien mais
on prend on prend met alors en ce moment
se tient jusqu'au 8 mai l'exposition
tous à la plage ville balnéaire du
xviiie siècle à nos jours elle présente
la singularité de l'architecturé de
l'urbanisme des bords de mer en france
du xviiie siècle au début des années
2000 regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
miss de ville d'arcachon encore le
touquet ces villes balnéaires ont vu se
développer la pratique de la
villégiature au milieu du xviiie siècle
à l'époque réservé à une élite
aristocratique
c'était plutôt un lieu de sociabilité
puis la coutume du banc de mer va
apparaître d'abord pour des raisons
dites médiques 1 alors évidemment pas du
tout comme nous aujourd'hui
donc il ya des images très amusante de
dames avec des maillots très couvrants
qui sortent de leur cabine alors
vraiment rien à voir avec nos petits
bikinis qui sont d'ailleurs aussi évoqué
dans l'exposition tous à la plage ville
balnéaire du xviiie siècle à nos jours
retrace l'architecturé l'urbanisme des
bords de mer en france cette exposition
itinérante produite par la cité de
l'architecturé du patrimoine est visible
jusqu'au 8 mai au palais du roi de rome
à rambouillet beaucoup d images qui
présentent les différentes pratiques des
vacances en bord de mer dès qu'on arrive
dans les périodes plus récentes et d'un
chacun peut sur peut s'y retrouver pour
retrouver l'image du village de vacances
qui là qu'il a pu voir enfants apeurés
des aussi au grand hôtel des panneaux
explicatifs et des vidéos illustrent
notamment la mode balnéaire dans les
années 1920 1930
[Musique]
vous c'est l'époque dans
l'entre-deux-guerres on commence à
s'exposer au soleil donc il commence
vraiment à voir des vêtements dédiés à
cette pratique de la plage en fait donc
les premiers mâts vrai maillot demain
alors très couvrant bien sûr encore pour
des questions de pudeur mais quand même
des ateliers pour enfants autour de
l'exposition seront organisées du 25
avril au 8 mai au programme
reconstitution de cabines de plage ou
encore création de leur propre
collection de maillots de bain
elles gardent rouillé comment avez vous
sélectionné les expositions temporaires
que vous proposer aux visiteurs alors
nous avons des lignes de programmation
qui sont définies en accord avec le
maire et la direction de la culture
donc avec des programmations qui est
assez éclectique à ces diverses pour que
les habitants et les visiteurs puissent
tous ils trouvaient leur compte dont des
expositions beaux-arts bien sûr
d'artistes vivants notamment mais pas
que
et puis nous avons notamment également
un axe de programmation qui tourne
autour du patrimoine rambolitains qui
est liée à la convention ville d'art et
d'histoire donc à 7 ce projet qui est de
vraiment de faire découvrir le
patrimoine aux habitants et aux
visiteurs
il se trouve à rambouillet que nous
avons une importante
un important patrimoine de la
villégiature donc cette pratique sociale
qui va du 19e en tout cas à rambouillet
du 19e à la première moitié du xxème qui
est de venir en vacances on imagine pas
mais ce fut un lieu de vacances de
villégiature avec des maisons très
particulière donc ils s'inspirent
parfois larchitecture balnéaire et donc
on a voulu faire le lien et accueillir
cette exposition qui est emprunté à la
cité de l'architecturé et du patrimoine
et qui raconte voilà l'histoire de
l'architecturé balnéaire de la recherche
de la villégiature depuis le 18è à nos
jours donc c'est une expo qui a apprécié
parce qu'il ya un petit côté nostalgie
chacun y trouve ses souvenirs de
vacances et
j'ai vu que le musée était labellisés
musées joyeux qu'est ce que cela veut
dire alors le label musée joyeuse s'est
décerné en fait par une association qui
s'appelle mot mart et qui veut favoriser
la visite du musée en famille donc la
saison moment reconnaît les musées qui
font des efforts pour accueillir les
familles alors ça passe par le fait
d'offrir des des petits jeux aux enfants
des petits kits de visites des énigmes à
résoudre des enquêtes
et ce depuis la petite enfance jusqu'à
l'adolescence et même plus j'ai vu aussi
fort vous m'avez vous m'avez dit que le
pavillon du verger va rouvrir bientôt
qui se situe juste à côté du musée c'est
bien ça exactement
donc le palais du roi de rome donne sur
un jardin en jardin du roi de rome et
dans ce jardin se trouve aujourd'hui un
petit monument un pavillon de jardin
appelé papillon du verger qui date du
xviiie qui lui est donc antérieure et ce
pavillon qui a été commandé par le duc
de louis 15 vient de faire l'objet d'une
très très belle restauration donc la
restauration est achevée pour le
monument elle en train elle va se
terminer très bientôt pour le décor
intérieur les abords vont être qualifié
il y aura peut-être d'ici 18 mois à deux
ans de nouveaux jeux d'enfants installé
dans le jardin et ça a vraiment ça va
être très très beau et on ouvre début
juillet très bien merci beaucoup el
guerrouj est d'avoir été notre invité
merci les archives départementales des
yvelines organise jusqu'au 23 avril un
nouveau concours au numérique baptisé
d'énigmes la dame aux faucons sous forme
d'une enquête à résoudre les
participants plongeront au dans des
documents d'archivés on en parle avec la
responsable chargée de développement des
publics des archives départementale des
yvelines
[Musique]
l'énigme est un concours qui est ouvert
à tous
et c'est un concours numérique dont
comme en fait les énigmes sont sains
sont à résoudre exclusivement en ligne
sur le site internet des archives et
donc il s'agit d'un parcours avec une
série de deux petites enquêtes une série
de petites questions qu'il va falloir
résoudre en allant chercher et en
consultant des documents d'archivés dans
ce concours en fait il y a deux
catégories vous avez une catégorie quand
son public qui est ouverte donc vraiment
à tout voir résidente en france et une
catégorie spécifique pour les collégiens
des yvelines
[Musique]
cette année on s'est focalisé vraiment
sûr sur le moyen-âge et cette fameuse
dame au faucon dont il va falloir
retrouver l'identité on va sur la trace
de personnages qui ont réellement existé
et donc pour trouver justement à
l'histoire et la mémoire dans les
documents des archives
[Musique]
le concours pas récompensé
trente joueurs grand public et 30 soir
collégiens on va pouvoir gagner des
tablettes des ordinateurs des drones
[Musique]
après la mer s'est évaporé c'est le nom
de l'exposition de jeanne coop visible
jusqu'au 21 mai à la graineterie à
houilles l'artiste international
présentera ses oeuvres mais aussi les
installations spécialement conçu pour le
liévinois chaque espace amène à une
découverte une trentaine de pièces en
céramique des éponges suspendus ou des
cartons d'emballage est né en allemagne
installés en france l'artiste
international jan kopp a investi les 350
mètres carrés du centre d'art de la
graineterie yaoi quand on parle du
travail de jan kopp généralement ce qui
ressort tout de suite c'est la grande
variété de ses productions yann c'est à
la fois un vidéaste c'est un dessinateur
il produit des installations il produit
des sculptures verrière galerie grenier
chaque espace de la graineterie est
investi pour cette exposition très
personnel qui oscille entre les
différents espaces temps et moi c'est
vraiment cet aspect du travail de yann
qui m'intéressait beaucoup puisque alors
sans être architecte les questions
d'architecturé espaces c'est vraiment un
fil conducteur dans la carrière de
l'artiste et il a vraiment cette
capacité d'inventer de réaliser des
oeuvres et des installations qui sont
toujours extrêmement juste par rapport
au lieu qu'il investit pour cette
exposition baptisée après la mer s'est
évaporé l'artiste a produit
spécifiquement pour la verrière de la
graineterie une installation poétique à
partir des planches de mer
il a collecté 7 ou 8 éponge de mer c'est
ce que vous pouvez voir vraiment autour
de vous et il invite le visiteur à
marquer une pause puisque cette
installation et mobile est en fait en
fonction des conditions climatiques en
fonction d'un système de poids et de
balancier tout ce que vous voyez votre
autour de vous est amené à bouger
lentement ou pas autour de l'exposition
à parcours sensoriel est proposé pour
les enfants de 6 à 36 mois
les plus grands pourront ainsi découvrir
d'autres ateliers adaptés à leur âge
et c'est la fin de cette fuite culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez-vous à
la semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel yvelinois bonne soirée sur tv5
[Musique]